brooklyn nine-nine season two
episode 13
meatball
marinara sauce cannoli
bacon
broadway
jaywalking okay guys yelling new year
using your hands
well we go watch this you know what to
do just please hit that like button if
you can go ahead and do that catch up on
our other brooklyn nine-nine reactions
there's a there's a playlist for y'all
also uh full-length watch logs oh god
god dad i don't want to say it let's
just watch this thanks for the people
that prep for episode
[Music]
invite him over order some fancy takeout
throw it in a pot and act like you
cooked it i got the idea from yahoo
answers dude i'm not gonna buy a pot
we're not married okay you know what
time it is
because my hoodie does
everything's gonna be booked we're only
72 hours out and we're still in the
brainstorming phase you gotta postpone
you can't postpone a birthday amy but if
you can't get a reservation you can
always go home and shampoo his hair
please stop always recommending that
well it's always romantic
i think that's very romantic huh
maybe i will you compete on the whole
city from up there come on
i wonder if anyone's tried that hey
sarge can i borrow a dollar you already
owe me way too much the bank of terry is
closed what are you sailing away on a
tugboat man i love tugboats it's not a
tugboat i'm locking the vault
we owe you 50 60 bucks 2 437
wow i would appreciate it if you paid me
back that's the craziest thing anyone's
ever said to me i would appreciate it if
you paid me back good so you heard it
too
i'm gonna drop everything and figure out
why he's acting weird
[Laughter]
fact the first after years of not caring
about my debt you weirdly want me to pay
you back now that implies to me that
there is a sudden unexpected expense or
i got sick of waiting for you to do the
right thing not plausible
you've had dentist appointments twice in
the past two weeks no one goes to the
dentist that much i haven't been in
seven years you should go to the dentist
jake probably my teeth hurt all the time
oh yeah i'm really liking this fact the
thing i'm gonna stick with it fact the
fourth
[Laughter]
you terry jeffords are pregnant the
names are baby names the dentist an
obstetrician and the money is for baby
things talking about man
that is crazy
damn it
we just found out sharon is pregnant and
it's way too early to tell anyone
this is a secret
do you understand why is so bad i don't
know look i promise i won't tell anyone
all right my lips are sealed good
do i even weigh anything to you no
okay partner let's bang this out should
we grab a cup of coffee bounce some
theories off each other i solved it
already
richard wilcox a firefighter who was
first on the scene at all three fires
now which have to work backwards figure
out why promotion and wanted to look
like a hero yep but
how are we gonna find this bastard after
all these years he owns a store i have
the address
there you are sergeant installment one
of tbd 1200 bucks that's everything i
have you should also note it's all in
singles because it takes so many bills
to fill up a briefcase
[Laughter]
oh also i put a list of baby names in
there my favorite nakatomi after the
tower in die hard works for a boy or a
girl what's going on
how'd you get all that money
by putting bad guys behind bars i work
for a living
you guys got in my head about owing
terry money and it convinced me that
it's important to pay back your friend
gaslighter oh no
all right how much do i owe the rest of
you four thousand and nine dollars what
how is that even possible june 3rd 2008
paid for your lunch eight dollars and 45
cents june 3rd 2008 bought you soda
dollar five cents you're like my mom
dollars for an entertainment system
i'm sorry you guys but i can't pay that
it's too much money why don't you just
take back the money you gave to terry
and split it six ways and at least
everyone gets something yeah but terry
needs the money for what but enhancement
surgery smart that's a real problem area
for terry yeah oh
not having butt enhancement surgery nor
do i need it your butt's great terry two
coffees black for me
milk for you you remembered how i like
it yes with milk just one ingredient and
you remembered it
[Laughter]
grab a little chow don't eat
i brought these
nutrition bricks
[Laughter]
or we could grab a little street meat
huh
meat
from the street
sounds like a fun
a
treat
and didn't even know i was rhyming those
words
damn this bike's muddy and this isn't
even the worst thing i had to do gina
made me call people and tell them she
was dead to see how they'd react
lower i'm at your butt lork apparently
he carries his stress in the beat cheeks
oh god
i'm so sorry
well at least i can help you out no no
no terry legs is yogurt i want you to
wash my dogs hmm why would i ask that
given that i know you hate my dogs they
hump everything they're passionate but
you don't have to wash them at all if
you just tell me what's going on here oh
no we don't have a secret all right do
we have a secretary yeah we did it's a
secret for me
okay then watch my dogs and be warned
they just watched peabody and sherman so
they're extra horny
quiet you may be worth it man
i'd rather be a godfather is this sauce
for your chicken or my lamb
i don't know should we try it let's
whisk it oh
i love when they bond
it's amazing i'm careful work
but i try
and what a story for kevin
he was a great partner smart
loyal homophobic but not racist
oh no
[Laughter]
you're not richard wilcox that's my
grandpa he died a couple weeks ago i'm
just here cleaning out his shop oh no
something is wrong with my intestine due
to the street meat
we must go now
okay
oh no bathroom no this is a very private
emergency oh golly
oh no
do not [ __ ] in the car
with you and terry the money the private
combos i figured it out you stole my
idea to open a bowling alley and you're
gonna do it with terry
yep that's it jake finger holes was our
idea oh
yes
yes yes
oh my god terry's pregnant what oh you
sent it hit reply all on the email
grandma peralta
good
great
the secret is out
no say it was a joke it's way too soon
to tell anyone i only stumbled across it
because i'm such an amazing detective
who accidentally hit reply all like some
idiot
[Laughter]
all right we just have to break into his
email account delete the message while
he's down at the gym great all right
here's the plan i'll go down what are
you gonna do jake i'm obviously about to
say
get my email
about how i was coming down here no i
haven't checked my phone ah
no need i just wanted to make sure
you're here you know you know how i like
to have a weight mate really
i have never seen you in the gym what i
basically live here no there's one
episode so take me through your workout
man rip me up you know let's rip it out
time to rip it down those aren't gym
times
and i don't think you can handle my
workout oh wow sounds like a challenge
to me come on
no no no
yes
largest password big muscles
nope that's your first guess big muscles
trey's wife's name's sharon
nope sharon won nope sharing two nope
sharing three nope this is stupid
[Laughter]
oh man
this is almost too easy are you crying
[Laughter]
call sharon and get back to work no no
no hey i thought you said
this was gonna be a challenge huh it's
been a cakewalk so far
oh you want me to make this harder yes
that is what i want more harder
exercises
burn 200 calories that's your heart rate
yeah that checks out
come on jake ten more minutes
i think we should stop now pearl no no
i'm still good
check this out
right here
[Laughter]
god i hate how hard it is to guess other
people's passwords wait everyone wait
try yogurt oh no
we're in yeah
[Applause]
terry loves yogurt
great i'm done great workout sarge
oh no i need to throw away this piece of
paper and i can't move my body on it
jakey it's showtime here we go
i love this we're like batman and alfred
you'd rather be alfred than robin he has
access to the batcave plus he gets to
drive all of that man's girlfriend's
home and dish joy
oh hey
how are you mrs sarge you look normal
for the paper hey jake
charles into the void of continuity my
emails and then i'll be ready to go
okay all set
all right have fun he's going to say
something no
no no
no no but i got the congratulations are
in order
for what oh peralta sent everyone in the
office an email about what name your new
baby but what it's worth i really like
the name
todd
you promised you wouldn't tell anyone i
know but i can't help it if everyone in
this precinct is a brilliant detective
you emailed them all
yeah yes that was one fact that may have
helped them crack the case but boyle was
closing in i was actually way off all my
fears were pulling alley related
how are you feeling better today i
haven't managed to eat some plain toast
this morning smart
something bland that's my favorite
breakfast
yes it is
on our second day as partners martin
o'mancoffee was kicked in the crotch by
a police horse of all the cases that we
worked that moment was the one that
bonded us the most because that's what
we laughed about after a surgery and
months long rehab it was a terrible
ordeal for both martin and heather
ormand
[Music]
laugh about me poisoning you yes i do
oh
perhaps over
street league
sir did you just laugh abroad recently
a
get ferocious of here
it's the rest of the money i owe you
1237 bucks i thought you already drained
your bank account i sold my car
it's not a big deal
oh my god this is such a huge no
no
yeah i was gonna say it's a nice car
the best i can do is make sure no one
talks about it for the next four weeks
and pay back your money so
jake hold up
yeah
i was wondering if you still want to be
the godfather oh
seriously
yes of course that would be amazing
thank you
i'm gonna be such a good godfather
you'll see i'm gonna be like what's the
matter with you be a man
i scream that other baby that was a bad
quote to choose but you go
[Laughter]
but if anything happened to me and
sharon you're responsible enough to
raise a little guy
that's what a godfather does
i mean i knew that
i can handle it or better yet what's a
good movie on parenting terry
seriously i have no idea what to do
yahoo answers
[Music]
yeah always
uh that was
that was a [ __ ] hilarious ass episode
it was a journey that was so [ __ ]
funny oh my god
oh
that's that's gotta be one of my faves
oh yeah
yeah
upper echelon of the beach that was
really funny that was not my cup of tea
and everyone had a good good moment at
some point oh yeah
very very
all right
let's break down the hidden meetings of
brooklyn nine-nine ending experience
that was so
so well done like i i think it was so
great how
it built up so well with the rhythm and
the way it was shot because they had i
really noticed it in the scene when they
were eating street meat or like the
interaction between
holt and amy how it was like this is so
simply shot when they're just hanging
out like they're not doing any
zooms or anything it's just like it's
actually like taking its time it's doing
like this
cutting back and forth or something that
feels more patient about it
instead of like the
the wacky rhythm it can sometimes be uh
which i adore about this show i'm just
saying like it was it was feeling like a
different type it was moving more like a
comedy movie versus a show at that point
and then when the street meet kicked in
and it just goes into this like anxiety
mess yeah
that looked like a real like chase scene
it almost felt like if phil lord and
chris miller directed this episode which
i know they've been involved with before
but it had a bit of that
um like
21 jump street vibe we're just watching
like a real scene and it kind of becomes
like chaos all of a sudden yeah and then
it's also
paralleling the anxiety that jake is
going through uh like you have these two
these two things where everything's
going smooth everything's going well and
then [ __ ] haha [ __ ] hits the fan and
like really
really strong and then you just watch it
like yeah
the stress unfold and everyone is so
funny in this episode i thought all them
had like different moments to do like
they gave like they boiled different
things to do versus just being like
overly supportive he was one of the
people people mad at jake yeah yeah he's
busting his cha i mean he's one of the
people who busted his chops the most
focally the whole thing about like dogs
you open up a bowling alley and they
pull like finger holes you're not going
to call up your girls like that is
it's freaking hysterical and then like
trying to jack into the password i think
most of us at some point in time have
had situations where we like we feel we
owe people money we we have a debt or
you're trying to figure out a password
you know these are all like relatable
situations so i let out a secret
prematurely yeah yeah yeah i think i
think these a lot of these are very
relatable or like you accidentally text
the wrong person or accidentally send an
email you know like we've all
not i can't say all but i think most of
us have encountered something along the
lines so i thought it was really cool to
keep it within the cop world that very
relatable things that can go wrong
eating something and getting diarrhea
like
you know
i thought this was just a great
um yeah it was a great episode and then
wrapped it up with a really nice heart
like a little bow to it with both amy
and holt yeah
along with you know obviously terry and
jake at the same time too it would just
seem like so like jake did not realize
what it means to be a godfather yeah
which is probably a great memory jogger
for a lot of viewers
who are used to hearing the term and not
realizing the true response the honor
and responsibility
yeah this was a
solid ass episode to me it started off
like
like all right outside of brooklyn i'm
usually like all right let's just see
how this goes and then
this this just kept ramping up and
getting funnier as it went so like once
it started getting funny it just kept
getting funnier yeah yeah it got funnier
it got more endearing as it got more
chaotic and as more of the plates
started to topple and yeah and i really
like like yeah it seems like the two
main pairs
are jake and terry and then uh holt and
amy and i really like seeing andre
brower and melissa romero play off each
other like i
i appreciate you know there is i think a
frequent like
approach they can take it's like okay
well this episode will pair off a couple
characters you don't normally see
together like
fully
and uh yeah i really loved what they
made out of both of those uh you know
like the the whole bit where he laughs
uproariously like that is like character
growth in a way and it's also some of
the most animated we've seen hold but
it's also a nice touching little moment
and i love that you know that mystery
flows out of a prior episode savant the
hacker is of a prior episode they're not
huge details
but at the same time they make
everything feel a little more alive and
then yeah you have these two main duos
driving the episode and then the rest
speaks to just how good the rest is of
the cast of being an ensemble and really
supporting even when their characters
aren't the focus of whatever plot lines
or whatever well yeah there was such a
pulse to this episode like the in the
last half a lot of the scenes were were
short that's what i thought was clever
like they had full scenes and the last
half was a lot of short short scenes
because you're cutting around to a lot
of different like
problem-solving chaotic situation
keeping secrets yeah um
you know like like when they're trying
to hack into the password i thought that
was like really funny the way they
handled that yeah uh for one share two
three this is stupid yeah
like it was just it was such a quick
scene but it was it was perfect you know
yeah i think they i think they nailed it
i think what they did with holt
was i i feel like they've kind of been
showing more of a
a more animated side of him recently in
the in this season like having bits or
moments where he's kind of breaking
against the norm of how we portray him
and this actually
brought him back to
more of that robotic halt yeah for that
you got accustomed to in the first
season
where it is like everything amy's just
very emotional he's just remarkably
playing the straight man the dry humor
yeah you know
which makes for wonderful attention yeah
yeah so i think that was uh
i think that was cool to get that
version back instead of a really because
he has been more expressive lately to
put himself into situations to be more
expressive
and
uh yeah so i like getting it back to
more of the
robot hole yeah absolutely and yeah yeah
and and having i yeah i just really like
having them paired up together because
like terry and and and jake is like a
well-worn duo where it's like oh if it's
a terry and jake episode like that's
usually a treat usually a lot of fun uh
and you know amy's character is so often
directed toward holt but not really in a
position to be connected with him and
yeah just some of their banter back and
forth and some of the little jokes like
it it's good because it plays on the
dynamics you already know and the
awkwardness of who they both are and yet
it still manages to be endearing and you
still buy that that bond is forming by
the end
and i appreciate how they do set up that
they would be working this case together
which almost landed her in hot water but
then made her partner
and that when this episode kicks off
he's already solved it and decided so
the
them doing this task together is not
about the mission or solving the case or
putting someone in jail
it's more about this memory that they're
going to create together you know yeah
it's about you know giving something
like uh uh
giving something to her gesture in doing
that yeah yeah man i really liked it a
lot uh this was uh this is one of my
faves i really i thought this was like
it's the kind of comedy i would like to
if i were i don't ever write comedies
weirdly unless if it's like a stupid
opening sketch for this channel but i
don't really write i don't write
comedies so i would if i ever wrote a
comedy i love these are my favorite
types of that have
um
like a backdrop of intensity to it yeah
yeah yeah some kind of that number it's
like overshadowing like the hangover
three where it's like only intense it
doesn't feel like a comedy yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
related
you know yeah
so i really understood not
life-threatening intensity but yeah
interpersonal intensity yeah exactly
that's a great way to put it all right
guys what'd you think about this episode
this was uh this is hilarious i'm glad
we watched it
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
thanks to the prepper boys we'll catch
you guys soon
you